hi my name is lima murshi
i'm very excited to be here today
together with my colleague mihayla
vorvaranu
to present this webinar on how to create
human-centered ai
with the human ai experiences toolkit
this is a collaboration between
microsoft research and ether which is
microsoft's advisor committee on
ai ethics and effects in engineering and
research
so before we begin a little bit about me
i'm a senior principal research manager
at microsoft research
where i manage the human ai experiences
group
i also co-co-chair the ether working
group on human ai
interaction and collaboration and i'll
be sticking around after the
presentation so i hope you stay for the
live q a
so in this webinar we're going to talk
about human-centered ai
what is it and why do we need it and
then we'll introduce the hacks toolkit
which contains a suite of tools we've
been developing to help ai creators and
teams
build ai technologies in a
human-centered way
okay so first what do we mean by
human-centered ai
why do we need it so let's start with
some context
here you see a map of the 2020 data and
ai landscape
published every year by first mark
venture capital and this just goes to
show the breadth and the reach of ai in
our everyday applications and services
and how it's fundamentally shaping
and reshaping our everyday technologies
now while we know
ai and machine learning technologies are
very powerful
and have the potential to enhance our
capabilities and improve our lives
as ai extends into every aspect of our
lives
we're also starting to see more and more
evidence of its potential to cause harm
and for this i'd say you know pick your
headlines right
on the left here we see computer vision
technology used to help blind and low
vision people
sense who and where people are in their
environment
whereas on the right we see the same
technology used by law enforcement
officers in new york
who use an undisclosed facial
recognition system to find and harass a
black lives matter activist here named
derrick ingram that you see here
and so it's because of this potential
for harm
that society is really starting to
demand change
and accountability particularly for when
ai is used in critical
and sometimes life-changing scenarios
so the industry is really being called
upon right now
to reflect and rethink how we build our
ai technologies to ensure that we do so
in a responsible way
now there are many challenges to
creating ai responsibly
this includes cultural challenges around
shifting people's mindsets and embracing
diversity throughout the
process organizational challenges
including aligning business and
responsible ai objectives and making
room for this type of work
but today i'll be focusing on the
technical challenges
meaning challenges around how we build
our ai technologies
in a responsible way now when i say
technical
i won't be talking about algorithmic and
challenges or automated solutions for
building ai
and that's not because it's not
necessary it's because
we're actually quite a long way from
purely technical solutions
that can automate all aspects of
developing ai technologies
and in fact we may never get here
because a lot of responsible ai
requires human judgment and decision
making
so this is what i'll be talking about
today i'll be talking about how we can
support
our the people who are building our ai
technologies
so they can do so in a responsible way
this is where human centeredness comes
in okay
that is building ai responsibly really
requires that we adopt
human-centered practices okay so what's
that
so people use this term in many
different ways i like to relate it back
to
its origins in human-centered design
which says
that it's about ensuring that what we
build
benefits people and society and that how
we build it
begins and ends with people in mind
okay now you may be thinking you know
the sounds
nice and you know it's a very warm and
fuzzy concept but how do we actually
do this in practice
okay now there's some general best
practices for building ai
in a human-centered way this includes
first thinking about the user early and
using that understanding about the users
to drive
all other technical decisions of the
system
so what that means is that human
centeredness prescribes
doing all that upfront understanding and
research about your users
and the variety of contexts in which
they may be using your system
and you use that to drive all other
decisions about building
your ai based technology so for example
if your ai is supposed to work on a
broad range of people
your data that you should collect should
be representative of all of those people
similarly if your ai technology is going
to need to provide an explanation to a
user so that they can make appropriate
decisions
it's best to choose some sort of
interpretable model
or choose a technology that can generate
an explanation
now another best practice in human
centered ai is that
if your ai is intended to work for a
broad range of people and scenarios
it's important to involve diverse
perspectives throughout development
so that includes talking to diverse sets
of potential users
but it also can involve diverse members
of your team
team being involved throughout the
development process
when such as when making critical
decisions about the system's
functionality and capabilities
similarly human centered ai suggests
planning for failures
so that people can recover when things
inevitably go wrong
okay so these are just some of the best
practices for human-centered ai
but it's easier said than done so
in this work we created a toolkit to
help
the hex toolkit is a set of tools
that can help operationalize
human-centered practices
for creating responsible ai so in the
rest of this talk we'll be introducing
you to some of the tools in the toolkit
that you can start using
right away so currently the toolkit
includes these tools
that help with different parts of the ai
product development process
and more will be coming soon and all of
these are available at the link that you
see on the screen
the first tool is the guidelines for
human ai interaction
which prescribe best practices for how
ai systems should behave
during human ai interaction the second
is a hacks workbook
which is a tool to guide teams through
planning and implementing human ai
interaction best practices
the hacks design patterns are a set of
flexible and reusable solutions to
recurring
human ai interaction problems and
finally the hex playbook is a
tool for generating scenarios to test
based on likely human ai interaction
failures
okay so let's dive in so first the
guidelines for human ai interaction
so the guidelines were a collaboration
with people across microsoft
um including research and product to
synthesize and validate
best practices for human ai interaction
and now we created the guidelines
because not only is ai extending into
our everyday lives and our technologies
it's also fundamentally changing how we
interact with those technologies
for example it's introducing new methods
of interaction and new sensing
capabilities
so along with changing how we interact
with our systems that's also creating
new challenges
for the people who have to interact with
them and we see this in everything from
humorous ai failures like when our
conversational agents
misunderstand us like you see in this
example here
to really dangerous situations like when
ai is being used in high-stakes
scenarios
right so over on the right we see an
image of a semi-autonomous vehicle
where what happened here was the vehicle
missed a fire truck stopped on the road
and the driver was not able to intervene
in time
okay so we created the guidelines to
help ai design and developers
create safe and effective human
interaction with ai
now i won't get into details of how we
created the guidelines
other than we did four rounds of
synthesis iteration and evaluation of
the guidelines
with over 60 user experience
professionals so you can learn more
about this
in the paper but the point here is just
to say that we didn't just make these up
we endeavored to take a very systematic
and rigorous approach to develop the
guidelines
so we ourselves could feel confident in
their effectiveness
now uh before i introduce the guidelines
just some disclaimers to follow like
as you're using them the guidelines
shouldn't be
thought of as a checklist and not all of
the guidelines will apply to every
human ai interaction scenario
additionally
additional guidelines may be necessary
in some scenarios
and you're really using the guidelines
in the right way if you consider them
during the development process
so here are the guidelines they're
broken up into four categories
roughly based on when they would apply
as a user interacts with an ai system
now these are rough categories not hard
assignments
that just make it easier to remember
so the first category is how an ai
system should behave
initially and this is really all about
setting the right expectations for
our users which is really important in
ai because
of the way that ais are portrayed in the
media
and because of their complexity that
really sets up sometimes unrealistic
expectations
for people when they use ai systems
which can then lead to problems
the second set of guidelines is about
how to design
every regular interaction with the user
and this is really about considering the
context in which a user will be
interacting with your system including
their environmental
as well as social context
the third category is all about what to
do
when the ai is inevitably wrong
and i can't stress this enough your ai
will fail
and so it's very important to design
interactions so that people can
understand
and intervene when that happens
and finally this the last set of
guidelines the last category here
is about how the ai should behave over
time
and this is really important in ai
because um one of the key benefits of ai
and machine learning technologies
is their ability to personalize and
adapt over time
but that has to also be done carefully
so that humans can effectively interact
with them
now i'm not going to get into details of
of the individual guidelines but you'll
be hearing about some of them throughout
the webinar but um they are being
used by teams across the company uh and
externally
and what some folks have said are that
these guidelines are all about creating
trustworthy and assistive systems
because what really matters here is the
model for human in a
human interaction with a system that has
been given
really tremendous authority over human
life in many cases
similarly another team that used the
guidelines
said you know it took us four years to
come up with 80
of what's in the guidelines and if you
institutionalize this into the design
parts of products
you really give people an opportunity to
build a much better product
in gen 1. right and that's really the
point right to help teams create
effective human ai interaction from the
start
now while teams are using the guidelines
um
and people have been eager to learn
about them we've actually conducted many
workshops and talks and engagements with
teams to help them use
the guidelines in their everyday
development processes
and in that in in working with teams
we've also learned about
challenges that they're facing in how to
apply these um in their everyday uh
work lives so for example um
some of the challenges people have said
are that
the guidelines are based a lot upon
engineering more than
design and some of the guidelines would
actually require a full scale overhaul
of the back end
right so that means that implementing
the guidelines
can't be done at the ui layer or at the
end
it has to be thought up up front
another challenge that we've heard is
that if the spec
doesn't have the guidelines or the
interactions built into
the from the beginning it's going to be
too rigid to respond
meaning if you miss a boat in the
beginning you just have to sort of yell
from the shore and ask them to like
change things
um and where they're steering things
which is obviously difficult to do
so to address some of these challenges
we created other tools in the hacks
toolkit
and so for this i'll hand it over to my
colleague
mihayla vorvaranu to introduce some of
our other tools
thanks salima i'm mikhaila vorovorano
i'm director of ux research and
responsible ai education for ether
and i'm super excited to walk you
through the next
two tools in the hacks toolkit so
we'll start with the hacks workbook
which is a tool to guide
teams through planning and implementing
best practices for human ai interaction
in this case our guidelines for human
eye interaction
before we launch into the next set of
tools i would like to give credit to the
team
these tools the workbook the design
patterns
the playbook were led by these
research interns you see on the screen
and you see the mentors at the bottom
of course the entire set of projects was
led by
salima okay so let's take a quick look
at the hacks workbook
this hacks workbook just like everything
we do
is grounded in observed needs and in
interviews
and it was actually co-developed
iteratively
with more than 40 practitioners or teams
across the company it uh supports
two goals for planning and implementing
human ai interaction best practices
first it helps teams define the right
breakdown and sequence of steps that are
needed to plan the ux
early and it helps them accurately
estimate
resources needed to implement the
guidelines
also the workbook provides the right
level of guidance
and prompts so that teams can
anticipate the impact of each guideline
on the user and the user experience and
thus
helps them prioritize the hacks workbook
is available in an excel spreadsheet
that anyone can download and use
and it consists of four main steps
followed by a fifth step for taking
notes and tracking
i will be walking you through each one
of the steps
first on the left side columns we see
each guideline along with a set of
examples for
how a team would answer for each of the
steps
for a fictional example for that
guideline
so let's see what step 1 entails
in step 1 the team would first go
through each of the 18 guidelines
and select which ones are relevant
as salima explained not all guidelines
are applicable
to all products and so for step one
for each guideline teams would answer
yes
no maybe or already done
of course they would do this for any
feature
or product they have in mind that is
ai powered and users
interact with once they make that
decision for their feature or product
for each guideline
they can filter and only see
the relevant guidelines before moving to
step
two in step two this is where
teams try to imagine or even better
conduct some user research
to estimate the impact of relevant
guidelines
on users and so the workbook guides them
with two questions how might it affect a
user
if you apply this guideline how might it
affect the user
if you choose to not apply this
guideline
and uh teams can type in their answers
below
and then taking those um into
consideration
um estimate the impact on the user
using high medium or low
then they can also sort or filter
to show only high impact guidelines in
an
effort to help them prioritize work and
move on to step
three so for the guidelines that they
have chosen as relevant in step one
and as high impact in step two they
start brainstorming
in step three requirements for
implementing this guideline
this is really really important to have
the entire team together
because implementing a guideline
requires
collaboration and has implications for
data science for program management
for user experience design and
research and so it's important to
brainstorm all of these requirements in
step three
and then using t-shirt sizing estimate
the resource
commitment for implementing each
guideline now in step four
we take into consideration the impact on
the user
and the resource commitment and then we
determine
what the priority is for each of the
guidelines that we've selected in the
previous steps
of course we can select using from p0 to
p3
and then in step 5 we can track work or
we could just move work items into
any sort of program and process
management software that a team might be
happening to use
so next i will be walking you through
these
steps using the example of a voice
assistant
that can call people or can remind you
to call people
and this is we're going to work through
this example
using guideline 10 scope services when
in doubt so let's see how we would be
answering at each step for step one is
this guideline relevant
we would answer yes if the assistant is
unsure whom to call
then asking for clarification is less
costly to a user than calling the wrong
person
right and so we would want to um
to pay attention to this guideline then
in step
two how might applying this guideline or
not
impact our users well a person may
become frustrated or embarrassed
if the assistant calls someone that they
didn't mean to
in step three we brainstorm how this
guideline might be
implemented and so here's what might be
required
first the ai model has to be able to
compute its own uncertainty
then when it is uncertain it has to act
somehow
in this case we can suggest uh it could
disambiguate the user's request by
asking them to
clarify whom they uh intend to call
and then in step 4 we make decisions
about this guidelines prioritization
in this case we say that the user
benefits
outweigh the resource costs but without
the
context of the other guidelines we're
not exactly able in this example to put
a p0123 on this particular guideline
and so we encourage teams to use this
workbook
early on when they have an idea
for a new user-facing ai feature
and they're starting to define
requirements
or when they have an existing
user-facing ai feature or prototype
that they want to evolve or improve
we also want to clarify and insist that
people
don't do this alone this is a team
exercise and it's really important to
involve
people and collaborators from different
disciplines
because implementing the guidelines can
impact a system's
not only ui but also data and ai
models we also encourage teams who use
this workbook
to engage with users and stakeholders
through user research
when using this workflow to better
understand their needs
their priorities and how they might be
affected
by applying or not applying some
guidelines
we have piloted this workbook with a
number of teams at microsoft
and here is what they had to say this is
a short selection
of quotes so a pm pointed out
that this is helpful also as a team
alignment tool
and trying to speak the same language
as the other side as the intelligence
side that they work with
having a framework to do that around is
very helpful
we see a lot of research in um about
ai practitioners that points to this
difficulty of communicating across
disciplines
and we are happy to see that the hacks
workbook can function as such a boundary
object
that can help people communicate
information
and collaborate across disciplines
an engineer said that they found a lot
of points they hadn't considered before
and so this was helpful
okay this is something that we've
observed again and again when
interacting with
um teams that piloted the workbook that
it helped them
think about how the feature should
behave and how it would evolve
in in ways that maybe wouldn't have
occurred to them
otherwise another pm said that this
is helpful for framing things to bosses
and to other disciplines as they
make arguments for resources and a
designer appreciating
um finding some sort of research
evidence in the guidelines
to support their design decisions
well and so having talked about the
hacks workbook which again we encourage
teams to download and use from the hacks
toolkit website
now we're going to move on to the next
tool in the toolkit which is the hacks
design patterns so first of all let's
talk a little bit about
design patterns what are they and why
are they
useful design patterns have been used
for a long time starting with
architecture then in
programming in design in art
as well they are useful because they
capture
flexible solutions to recurring
problems and so when we have a type of
problem
we can match it with a type of solution
and by using these established solutions
we can save time
and we can help create consistently high
quality user experiences
now i also want you to think about
the step in the workbook step 4
which asked how might you implement
a certain guideline at that particular
step
it would be useful to bring in the
design patterns
and as you've decided to implement let's
say guideline 10
we can browse through the design
patterns and see ideas for how we might
implement
that guideline so we have synthesized
and validated
33 design patterns for a selection
of 8 out of the 18 guidelines for human
ai
interaction we have selected guidelines
that we thought were
particularly unique and possibly
difficult
to implement in the context of human ai
interaction
we synthesize these patterns using a
collection
of examples for the guidelines that have
been
submitted through a previous user
research
project so
you can see here the list of patterns
and i'm going to illustrate
a pattern again for guideline 10
with the same scenario of a voice-based
virtual assistant
that can call people in this case
we have synthesized three patterns that
implement that can be used to implement
guideline 10
a disambiguate before acting b
avoid cold starts by eliciting user
preferences
and c fall back to other strategies
so in this case i pointed out that
disambiguating before acting might be a
more appropriate pattern
in for this scenario let's take a look
at what this pattern
looks like so this pattern
just like all the other patterns follows
a systematic structure with the same
headings
it has a problem statement a solution
statement
when to use how to use
and it further proceeds not shown on the
screen
into common pitfalls to avoid when
implementing this pattern
user benefits related patterns as well
as a list of references
that are useful in implementing this
pattern
or that have informed the writing of the
each pattern as well has at least two
examples in this case i'm going to show
you
one of the examples and this is a
predictive keyboard
that disambiguates before acting
by asking the user which one of the
three
likely words below the user was
intending to type
so in this case disambiguate before
acting
for our voice assistant um is
really something like who do you mean to
call do you mean to call
satya n or satya k
so with that i've provided you an
overview
of the hacks workbook and the design
patterns and i'm going to hand it over
back to salima
to talk to you about the hacks playbook
thanks mahala
so the final tool i'll introduce today
is the hacks playbook
which is a tool for generating scenarios
to test based on likely human ai
interaction failures
now we created this tool because while
we often do
offline tests of model performance we
typically do
less testing with humans in the loop
prior to deployment
in fact through interviews with
practitioners spanning dozens of teams
working on ai-based systems
we found that in many cases human ai
interaction testing
was hardly happening at all when it was
happening
it was often focused on testing the
ideal
or mvp scenarios or sometimes called the
hero scenarios
and if error cases were tested at all it
was often done in an
ad hoc way like using a trial and error
type of
approach one person said you know
there's not much of a discipline
around going through and evaluating or
auditing the error states
or how you're going to handle those
errors
one of the main reasons now people gave
for not testing ai experiences
was really the difficulty and
anticipating the types
and the range of ai failures that could
potentially occur
and that's because ai is probabilistic
it's designed to generalize to new
scenarios
and can learn over time all of which can
make it difficult to know
when it could fail and so one person
said you know it's so hard to know
until the bad things happen which is
often
obviously not when we want to
notice a failure
so while it's true that it's hard to
know when an ai
may have any particular failure there
are actually some common and foreseeable
types of failures that we can plan for
and test in advance
so this is what the hacks playbook is
for it's a tool
intended to help teams proactively and
systematically explore
various human ai experience failures
that may occur
for their particular ai product or
feature
now the tool currently supports nlp
scenarios such as
search information retrieval dialog
systems
but it's open sourced and it's
extensible to other ai scenarios
okay so i'll switch over to the tool
so here is what the hacks playbook looks
like
the tool is based on a taxonomy of
foreseeable failures in nlp
that we developed together with
researchers and practitioners
in natural language processing while
also examining common
nlp products and tasks okay so the way
that you use the playbook
is by describing your ai feature
by answering a series of questions on
the left okay so going back to
the example we've been using throughout
this webinar of voice based personal
assistants
that you can ask to call people you can
as you can start answering the questions
based on that scenario
so um what is which of these systems is
closest to what you're designing
that would be a conversational ai system
um it's primary input modality
you know could be text or speech so we
would say speech
and you know will your conversational ai
system have a clear way of knowing when
it should trigger
in this case maybe you know we'd want to
be able to use some sort of wake word so
i'd say
no right as opposed to using a button or
some other clear
signal now if you've noticed
as i've been answering questions the
playbook has been generating a set of
test scenarios
that should be tested beyond the the
hero or mvp scenario on the right
right so for example um because your
system will be using speech
you'll have um you off you will
typically have
different types of input errors on
like transcription errors or noisy
channels
you might have errors in when the system
triggers
here for example you know the system
might be uncertain about when to
uh start up it may have missed a trigger
or it might trigger when it thought it
hurt a trigger
but it was actually a false positive
so the the playbook lists these types of
failure cases
along with actionable and contextually
relevant guidance about how to simulate
those errors during
testing and now if you use the tool
early enough in your development
processes you can actually explore
different choices to help you better
design
your user experience so for example if
these trigger errors are something you
want to avoid
you could explore different types of
errors you might have to deal with
by changing your response to that
question
now after going through this tool and
generating the set of test scenarios
you can export the scenarios to your
different project management tools
and you can use it so your team can
track the type of work that needs to get
done
so practitioners who co-develop this
tool with us
said things like this will really
standardize the error case design
the playbook forces a consistent bar
across different teams and in different
organizations
because as i said earlier teams are
really exploring the aerospace in a very
ad hoc
ways because of the wide range of errors
that can happen
making it difficult to foresee
also we also another use of the playbook
is to help interdisciplinary teams
communicate with each other
one designer that we worked with said
you know we sometimes feel like
we're speaking different languages and
the playbook puts everybody on the same
level
by using term terminology and
information about tests that the whole
team
can talk about together
okay so to summarize in this webinar we
introduce the hacks toolkit
which includes a set of tools for
creating responsible and human-centered
ai
you can start using these tools now at
the link below
and more tools that we're developing
will be coming there soon
and just for some takeaways i just want
to remind you that you know responsible
ai
really requires human-centered practices
and the hacks toolkit can help you build
your ai technologies in a human-centered
way
so we encouraged you to use them and
give us feedback
and to work with us to help people and
teams create responsible and human
centered ai technologies
so with that i'll end and thank you for
your time and please also stick around
after this for a live q a
hi everyone thanks for attending our
webinar on creating human centered ai
with the hacks toolkit
i'm selena merci i'm here with mahela
borvaranu who co-led this work
and over the next 15 minutes we're going
to answer some of the top questions that
have been submitted by the audience
so let's go ahead and get started
so our first question
is uh are there any overarching ethical
principles that are integral to the
hacks toolkit
uh that is a great question and yes
there are
microsoft has responsible ai
principles that drive all of the work
that we do across the company
these include fairness reliability and
safety
privacy and security inclusiveness
transparency
and accountability and so you can think
of the hacks toolkit
as being tools to help
product teams build ai systems
in a way that can achieve these
principles that can allow the end users
who are ultimately going to be using or
impacted
by an ai system to achieve these
principles
so thanks for so much for the question
um our next question
i'll hand it over to mickey for the next
one
thank you salima so the next question
asks whether
the um training
colleagues on using the hacks toolkit
whether there are any key specific
skills and expertise
that traditional hci practitioners need
for learning to use the hacks toolkit
and to that question i would answer
based on my own experience
yes and no so for a little bit of
context
um believe it or not my background is in
the liberal arts
i do not have a computer science major
and yet
somehow and uh some of them some people
might say miraculously
i ended up as a co-author on the hacks
toolkit
so what does this mean for you um i had
to learn
a lot along the way i had to learn
the fundamentals for machine learning
and how ai systems work without actually
getting so technical that i would
actually be able to
do that kind of technical work myself
and so
even if you look at the guidelines you
see that there are implications
for uh machine learning in applying the
guidelines i think it is important for
hci practitioners
to be somewhat aware of those
implications
but i don't think that they necessarily
need to become
experts i think what's really really
more important
is for everyone to have the patience
to collaborate and communicate with each
other
knowing that sometimes across
disciplines though even the language
that we use
might be different and so
the hacks toolkit helps support these
cross-discipline and cross-roll
discussions and collaborations but i
think
hci practitioners should launch into it
and use it
and try to learn a little bit but not be
intimidated because there's no
intimidating amount of learning that
needs to happen in my opinion
thanks so much mickey let's go to our
next question
which is does your toolkit also look
into
paying for impact as well as
interactions i'm specifically interested
in the return on investment and what the
ultimate
impact of implementing ai will be in
terms of loss
of employees and dramatic changes to
workflow are there ethical questions or
standards included or applied
this is an extremely important question
that we
think about a lot at microsoft and we
advocate for teams to think about this
very carefully this is really about
do you build an ai system or not at all
um and this is something that we don't
have
a tool for currently in the in the hex
toolkit this toolkit
assumes that you've made a decision to
build an ai system
how do you build it such that people can
interact with it appropriately
but these questions around should you
build something at all
are very important very difficult to
answer because
there are a lot of potential ways an ai
can go wrong that's something that we do
have in the hex toolkit we have some
ways to help
teams sort of proactively think about
ways that an ai can go wrong
but even with ais that don't go wrong or
are not
misused can have unintended consequences
and sometimes these are hard to
anticipate because they
are long-term consequences in some cases
or consequences that have
accumulated through use or of an ai
in our everyday lives so this is an
open problem that many in the industry
are thinking about including ourselves
if we do have guidance or tools that we
create that we can
we think teams can that can help teams
we will share them
in the hacks toolkit so thank you for
the question
mickey do you want to take the next one
yes and in the next question i'm
actually going to combine a couple of
questions that we've received for the
audi
from the audience and um both of them
ask about how to handle cultural
differences in and conflicting user
preferences
so for example if the product is being
used in very different
cultural contexts and some of these
contexts might be
varying also and might include
people from different cultural or
demographic
minorities and so i think that's on
a great question an amazing question and
really i would like to direct people to
guidelines five and six in our um
toolkit about delivering user
experiences
in ways that are in line with cultural
norms
and also mitigating social biases and
avoiding
um prop promoting or
existing unwanted stereotypes or biases
um in practice of course this is not
easy to do
but um really i cannot think of a better
way than
user research in order to understand
these cultures right the understanding
of culture
is traditionally the the work of
anthropology and ethnography
and i think user research can really
help us understand
um what these social norms and cultural
expectations are
and it's a really really great start in
beginning to
make decisions and mitigate these
these differences in order to serve
each population well and especially
avoid
underserving populations that might be
already
marginalized
thanks mickey i'll take the next one
we have a question saying is the hex
toolkit designed or meant to be an
evolving library
in other words given the rapidly
changing landscape of ai
how will the hex team monitor and if
needed adjust various parts of the
toolkit
i love this question because this is
exactly what we want
to do with the toolkit if you
should see some links to the right of
your screen which point to the toolkit
and on the toolkit website you can find
a way to
contact us with your feedback we're
researchers at heart we're always
looking to
learn and listen from the community and
evolve as we go
in particular the design library was
meant to be
an evolving and growing tool
so as the community learns about how to
develop
and interactions with a people in ai we
want people to
contribute to the library innovate in
new patterns
and new examples and share so that
others can learn and we can really
advance the field
so absolutely yes
so i think we have time for maybe one
or maybe two more questions at most
um i think this is the last one that i'm
going to take and maybe if there's time
salima can take
the very last question i would like to
answer
the question can you describe how
aspects of the toolkit overlap with
traditional user experience evaluation
methods
such as a cognitive walkthrough and the
key differences
this is an excellent question so if you
think about the cognitive walkthrough
for example
that is more of an evaluation method as
the original person who asked the
question said
now of course the guidelines could be
used for evaluation
however we find that when there is an
existing
ai feature or product that's being
evaluated using the guidelines
it might be too late to change anything
you might discover issues that you would
might want to fix
but these could be very very costly
because
the guidelines have deep implications
all the way down to the data that you
collect for
uh the ml model that powers the system
and so we don't think of the toolkit as
a method for evaluation
we think of the toolkit as a set
of methods for planning for human ai
experiences really early on
as soon as you have some idea for
an ai feature or product that you would
like to develop
it's also fine to use it for evaluation
also but really if you're using
these tools for evaluation only you
might find that it's too late and
there's not much you can do
to improve the human ai experience
so now i'm going to turn it over to
salima i don't know salima if you'd like
to take one more question
or just wrap up the session for us
yeah thanks mickey i think i'll answer
quickly answer one more question which i
think is important and then we'll wrap
up
um the last question is i'm a new
developer
in ai in ai and ml is a hacked toolkit
for a single user
or for a team which manages or someone
who manages a team
and this is a great question the hacks
toolkit was designed for
interdisciplinary
teams building responsible humane
experiences really requires all
disciplines to come together
including user research design
ai and data scientists engineers pms
and so it's designed for for all members
of the team
so with that i want to thank again
everyone again for attending today
we really appreciate your participation
and your interest in the subject
of creating responsible and
human-centered ai please visit the hex
toolkit
you can see links to it to the right of
your screen
use it contribute to it give us feedback
and we look forward to learning from you
so
thank you and have a great day